[Musique]
le marin shadoks court après les shadoks
de la lune ceci pour fuir plus vite ils
ont appelé leur vieux cosmo autobus
nous n'allons pas essayer de vous dire
comment tu un vieux cosmos bus faisait
pour marcher rouler ça serait une tâche
vraiment au trop plein gré et vous
expliquer comment l'astronome marché
s'était encore à ces choses là shadow
car avait c'était déjà un peu plus
compliqué pour le cos l'autobus alors là
il faudrait faire appel à des notions de
mathématiques shadoks tellement
compliqué que cela ne voudrais même pas
la peine d'essayer
nous essayerons quand même peut-être une
autre fois ci nous avons le temps pour
le mot moore gégène a juré d'en finir
une bonne fois pour toutes avec ce
manège là en commençant par le barrage
san roque qui faisait le plus de bruit à
chanter et à taper sur ses châteaux kaka
qui poussaient des cris d'orfraie les
pauvres mais jeunes vies tout de suite
que ça pouvait pas marcher parce que
vous comprenez tiré en l'air dans un
aéroplane par exemple ça va ça fait un
trou et d'ustensiles ton métairie dont
le loup et à plus forte raison quand
elle est en l'air cela ne fait propos du
tout et rien ne tombe gégène avait été
demandé conseil à ses amis les gimmicks
ici que naissaient en artillerie et
c'est très simple lui avait-il dit fait
donc usage de thé dons naturels dont
naturel bien sûr que n'a qu'à siffler si
free eh bien oui quand gégène sifflets
journée il pleuvait et si cela marchait
avec des nuages gros comme ça il n'y
avait pas de raison que cela ne marche
pas sur les deux ou trois malheureux
sodja doc qui soutenaient leur bateau eh
bien oui cela marche l'on tombe à
l'achat doc caravelle tomba le marin les
shadows qu'à claquer les matelots
toussaint tombe à dents longues en
retard a fait exprès et pour la première
fois de sa vie
le pirate shadoks connu la mer pour lui
c'était une nouvelle vie commençait
on
[Musique]